Speaker 1: Well, the bad news
for the failed twice indicted,
twice impeached former President Donald Trump
couldn't possibly be getting any worse. Just when
it seemed that maybe that Judge Eileen Cannon,
appointed by Trump, might be his saving grace.
In the federal classified documents case. We
have now learned that special prosecutor Jack
Smith might be preparing to hit Trump with 45
more charges in that classified documents case,
including potentially putting those charges
forward in a different venue. Like, for example,
New Jersey, where Trump's Bedminster resort
is located, which also appears to be the
scene of some of these alleged crimes.
In order to get around the possibility
that that Trump friendly judge Eileen Cannon
might be able to run interference from Trump,
what is all of this about? Well, let's explain
it first and foremost. Daily News report Special
counsel Jack Smith could hit Trump with up
to 45 more charges. Interesting. Trump, the
45th president, could be facing 45 more charges.
Special Counsel Jack Smith is reportedly ready to
drop a hammer blow of up to 45 additional criminal
charges on Trump in the classified documents case,
especially if Trump friendly judge Eileen Cannon
looks set to thwart the case. This is a super
important detail. Once we knew about the location
of that first set, 37 felony charges against the
failed former president being in South Florida.
And once we knew that Judge Eileen Cannon had been
randomly assigned to the case. Understandably,
I and you and many others said, wait a second,
someone Trump appointed is now going to be
involved in the disposition of this case. That
seems absolutely ridiculous. And it is ridiculous.
And there are calls for her to recuse herself,
etc.. But shortly after that, legal experts
realized or put forward the idea that, hey,
you know what? Not all of these alleged crimes
happened in Florida. Florida's Romero law at Mar
a Lago is in Trump had the bathroom document
dump there and all that. But some of this stuff,
it's very clear, happened in Bedminster, New
Jersey. You could charge Trump elsewhere in this
case. And that is exactly what is being looked at
here. The Daily News article says the ex Brooklyn
prosecutor is prepared to bring additional charges
in various federal jurisdictions against Trump
based in part on multiple additional incriminating
tapes of Trump. Now, I want to make sure that
people understand this, because, you know, these
MAGA people will go, Oh, they're just coming up
with ways to go after Trump. No, no, no, no, no.
First of all, federal prosecutions have latitude
in terms of where you bring charges. Secondly,
the tape right there, audio recording where Trump
is heard shuffling papers like Rush Limbaugh
used to do, and then showing people and saying,
but this is secret. This is classified. That took
place in Bedminster. So it is not a stretch to say
that Trump would be charged somewhere other than
South Florida. Prosecutors are readying what is
known as a superseding indictment, in part as
a backup plan in case Cannon seeks to stall or
derail the case against Trump that was filed in
the Southern District of Florida, in which Trump's
Maria Lago resort home is located. New charges
could come in the coming weeks. One likely venue
for these additional charges would be New Jersey,
because Trump allegedly kept and even showed off
some of the highly classified documents to his
aides at his Bedminster golf resort. Smith's
team is poised to stack on an additional 30
to 45 charges on Trump, as well as top aides,
based on what the paper described as fresh
evidence that is not yet publicly known,
including more tapes of Trump. So there are even
more recordings that have not yet been released,
even though we, of course, have some of the tapes
that have been released here as well. Important to
also mention this is separate from the potentially
forthcoming federal charges against Trump related
to the January six Trump riot insurrection,
for which the January 6th committee of the
last Congress referred criminal charges to the
Justice Department. That's being investigated.
We have the state charges in Georgia, which,
quite frankly, if you zoom out of all of this,
the state charges in Georgia may end up being
the most serious and or the most consequential
for Trump. We're waiting on that. We'll know about
it out of Georgia sometime between middle of July
into beginning of September, I believe it was.
Those are the dates. So this is this is we are
nowhere close to we are nowhere close to the
end of this entire thing. I you know, because
we're so patriotic here on the David Parkman
show, wouldn't it be great if 45 got 45 more
charges dumped against him during fourth of. July
week. I think that would be a very exciting thing.